EKIN KARASAN: My
name is Ekin Karasan,
and I'm a senior in electrical
engineering and computer
science.
So the goal of my project
was to use capnography
to diagnose between two
cardiorespiratory conditions,
congestive heart failure and
chronic obstructive pulmonary
disease.
So the problem is that there
are a lot of people suffering
from respiratory conditions.
However, the
diagnostic tests that
are used to diagnose
these conditions
require a lot of effort
from the patient,
and they might be very hard to
comply with if the patient is
under a lot of distress.
So what we want to do
is replace these tests
with capnography, which
is effort-independent
and very easy to comply with.
So capnography measures
the partial pressure
of carbon dioxide
in exhaled breath
as the patient is
breathing normally
and produces a graph
called a capnogram.
And these capnograms
have distinct shapes
for different
cardiorespiratory conditions.
So the first step is to produce
a mechanistic model that
is based on the
compartmental models
of the respiratory
system, that produces
an expression for the
partial pressure of carbon
dioxide, or the
capnogram, as a function
of respiratory parameters.
And these respiratory parameters
are physiologically relevant.
So the first step is to
pre-process our capnogram
to extract the portions of
the capnogram corresponding
to exhalations and then
fit our mechanistic model
to these exhalations to extract
these respiratory parameters
and use these respiratory
parameters to actually diagnose
between the two conditions.
So using these estimated
parameters in a training set,
we train a quadratic
discriminator,
and we use this quadratic
discriminator on a test set
and apply it on a
patient-by-patient basis
to obtain an accuracy
of around 87.5%,
which was very successful.